joining us on the phone now to talk
about the treatment of the many victims
is our own dr. David agus who joins us
from California dr. agus we just heard
Carter sayin the sheriff tell us earlier
that more than 400 people were taken to
the hospital
how do hospitals deal with a situation
like this when you have that volume all
at the same time well there needs to be
a triage program where you assess and
you say which individuals are too sick
that it can't breathe on their own and
probably aren't going to make it and
who's very ill but immediate
intervention will benefit from them and
it's a horrible decision to have to make
but you need to start to say where can I
use the man and women power I have to
save people dr. agus how and so how do I
explain how hospitals rehearse for
situations on terrible situations like
this how they prepare well they go
through the drills where they they do
the triage and rapid treatment and so
the triage is assessing is there an
injury in the brain so that they will
not be able to save this patient even
though they are doing some breathing now
or is this patient you know of a
situation where I could just plug the
wound and you know keep them stable
until there's time to assess them or
does this need to be immediately
assessed and then the patient will be
okay that triage is critical and knowing
and it's a very difficult thing
obviously because some people you're
gonna have to say these are people who
we are not going to be able to save even
though if the emergency room is empty
they would be able to save them I know
but David you're making a life-and-death
decision in these cases with second no
question about yeah and you have to
start two great people so that you can
save the most people the most casualties
and have the most people who make it
through the event it is a horrible
position to be in obviously as a percent
of work patients and we know that every
second is critical we've heard from
multiple eyewitnesses that it sounded as
if it were eight ten even 20 minutes
before it seemed like the gunfire
finally ended how big of a setback was
that to transporting victims to
hospitals if people were still waiting
for the shooting to come to an end
minutes are everything in these
situations and you know obviously the
more you believe the more your blood
pressure's gonna be down the more you
need in media intervention like a
transfusion
it's a classically when they get to the
hospital they can be tagged where
there's a red yellow you know green and
an obviously black or gray and so each
of those tags tells them who they should
play attention to at that moment we
arrived at the hospital David very
important point the Las Vegas police
tweeted out the location where folks can
go if they want to donate blood this
morning is there something you could say
or would say to folks living in that
immediate area well this was critical I
mean we saw in the 60 minutes story on
congressman Scalise last night that
blood donations are what saved his life
and so many of these patients blood
donation is the only thing that will get
them to the next phase which is
hopefully to a favorable phase so as
much as you can go in and donate blood
today every citizen can donate blood
today and hopefully reduce the number of
casualties by doing so yeah we've heard
two reports Davidov people who were
wounded but had to hide out and couldn't
see treatment immediately you touched on
it a minute ago where you said listen
it's so important to get help right away
what about those people the shape that
they must be in now yeah so I mean if
there any people out there the key is
applied pressure the leave the more we
can limit the bleeding the better the
outcome is going to be and so those
people when they come in obviously
there'll be significant blood loss and
right away they will be getting blood
that you know its own negative and so
because they don't know have enough time
to type those patients so especially if
you are in that category of o-negative
blood get in there right away and
everybody get in and try to donate blood
it's critical and of course right now
the focus is on keeping these victims
alive and and recovered and treating
them but we already hear the the mental
wounds that these victims the 22,000
spectators at this event they they're
witness to this mass carnage talk about
the months weeks in years ahead for them
trying to recover from what they
witnessed I can only imagine you know
the post-traumatic stress associated
with what was going on here this is
being at war and these people at this
concert were at war and so they're all
going to be significant manifestations
and that's something that obviously
after the event the medical community
will start to set up way
to deal with these individuals and
figure out how to help them as much as
possible but right now the focus is only
one thing which is saving lives yeah and
we know that hospitals prepare and train
for something like this but when it
happens David how prepared are you
really for 400 people coming into your
place all at one time
spread over different hospitals of
course you aren't even close I mean we
go through drills all the time for
earthquake for mass shooting et cetera
and you don't imagine it's going to
happen so you do the best you can but
there's trauma in every person you know
in that ER Deana the post-traumatic
stress is also the doctors and the
nurses and everybody dealing with it
they're not used to dealing with this
they weren't trained to being a war
either David how do they coordinate or
figure out which patient is going to
which hospital well it's based on time
and so you know the closest hospitals
are ones you're gonna say well listen I
can save this patient very quickly if I
get them there maybe a transfusion right
away we can stop that bleeding et cetera
this person is less critically ill and
can be you know transported 20 miles or
whatever the next hospital is away and
so somebody is at the ground they're
doing that central Trias and they are
key to saving life this person and as we
heard from Carter and many eyewitnesses
it wasn't just ambulances there weren't
enough ambulances to transport all of
those wounded and who were struck at
private cars
I'm sure taxi cabs and anything
available to take patients to hospitals
was being utilized how how rare is that
in an incident like this and does it
cause any confusion upon entering the
hospital oh it absolutely must I mean
but heroes are stepping up
heroes are stepping up and getting
people there because minute counts in
this situation when you're bleeding or
actually with a gunshot you're but you
know you're losing blood and if you get
that's a certain point it's almost
impossible to turn around so the quicker
you can get the patients in to try to
stop that bleeding and get them
transfusions the more lives you're going
to save so kudos to those who are
stepping up and doing this but yes when
you arrive at a we're used to somebody
getting off that Amiens and explaining
what's going on and giving all the
vitals and saying what's happening here
private citizen is bringing people in
there's nobody assessing that
to pee in the car alright dr. David agus
joining us on the phone this morning
doctor thank you so much for your time